Lee da young was at etaewon on Saturday
the night of the Halloween crowd Crush I
told people there was someone on the
ground there was nothing we could do I
wasn't strong enough to move her I saw
the crowd just fall forward I can't get
those images out of my mind
she's returned to grieve those who died
I really didn't want to come back but I
felt I'd regret it for the rest of my
life if I didn't
so I came to lay flowers and say a
prayer
she realizes she could just as easily
have been one of the victims and says
she feels lucky but also guilty
I feel like I've committed a sin I was
the only one that got out they were all
like my friends
I only found out the scale of the
disaster after seeing it on the news it
was so distressing
the memorial altar at itawon is one of
many set up across South Korea on
Tuesday president Yun sukyol and some
cabinet ministers came to pay their
respects majority of the shops around
the site of the accident are shut as a
mark of respect you get a sense that
this is a nation in Collective mourning
there is to a feeling of collective
trauma scenes of the disaster played out
in real time on social media and were
broadcast repeatedly for days after the
government has extended free counseling
services to not only those directly
affected but to the general public as
well the nation's mood is slowly
shifting to one of anger
the police chief who's faced repeated
questions about the Force's preparation
for and response to Saturday's accident
apologized on Tuesday
there were emergency calls about the
danger and urgency of the situation and
that a large crowd had gathered before
the accident occurred however we think
the police response to the emergency
calls was inadequate the president has
said South Korea's crowd control
measures will need to be stepped up an
investigation is underway as to how the
Stampede occurred Florence Louis Al
Jazeera Seoul